a car tester Sasha cannot describes the
newest addition to forces Boxster series
a spider a spider is traditionally the
crowning achievement of a series and the
Boxster Spyder is no exception
it conveys the essence of the Porsche
brand sportiness and in this case purism
the Spyder is the lightest and at the
same time most powerful vehicle in the
Boxster range the designers concentrated
on optimizing its driving dynamics the
two-seater mid-engine convertible has a
manual 6-speed transmission doing
without luxuries saves weight and the
Spyders lightness is probable every inch
of the way
sascha notes that the driver sits very
low in the spider this lowers the center
of gravity providing additional
stability unfortunately when you look
behind you you see almost nothing
especially due to the design of the new
trunk lid the driver has to look past
the two humps and it really stretches
next the 3.8 liter engine comes from the
Carrera S and generates 276 kilowatts of
power the Spyder Sprint's from zero to
100 in just 4.5 seconds Porsche says the
Boxster spiders fuel consumption is nine
point nine litres per 100 kilometers in
the sport plus mode the car
automatically doubled the clutches when
you shift gears the engine briefly revs
up making the transition much smoother
and providing a special sound experience
Sasha says the Porsche Boxter spiders
purism is lovely but leads to an
annoying inconvenience the roof police
motor has been removed so you have to
put the top down by hand
first you must unlock the soft top on
both sides then open the trunk
well done and then push the top down
into the trunk and then you have to
close the trunk and turn down the
latches separately on each side one tear
mumbling one fetishists
the Boxster Spyder is a centimeter
longer and 11 millimeters lower than the
Boxster GTS and the two humps called
streamliners located behind the roll
bars are real eye catchers part of the
Spyders purism is that air conditioning
and a radio aren't standard equipment
they're optional extras carbon fiber
bucket seats are standard and offer
plenty of lateral support in all
situations
Tasha says driving with the top down
lets you enjoy the sound of the 3.8
liter naturally aspirated engine when
you start the car you can set things so
that this button opens the flaps and
then the symphony begins
the Boxster Spyder weighs in at just one
point three tons
the lightweight roof with its unheated
rear window weighs 11 kilograms less
than the motor driven soft top found in
other Porsche Boxster's the big trunk
lid is made of aluminum saving weight
again the engine generates up to 420
Newton meters of torque that's 50 Newton
meters more than the Boxster GTS
standard dynamic transmission mounts
give the spider more stability on curves
targeted braking of the inside rear
wheel enhances steering precision
that Porsche book suspect driving a
Porsche Boxster Spyder is a fashion
statement in itself says Sascha so you
need worry that the wind is muster hair
or a campus flag did in the back the
trunk loads 130 litres that's not a
whole lot but there's also some room up
front enough for a weekend getaway with
your sweetheart
Sascha laments that fuel consumption is
so high nine point nine litres per 100
kilometres which drives co2 emissions up
to 230 grams per kilometer maybe it's
better to just look at this car and the
driver after stains Alison wouldn't
renew our answers on